this is a production of Cornell
University
so I've been the long long time ago just
for a quick visit to Colonel I think
actually it was 26 years ago I had the
pleasure to visit Connor and in winter
it's absolutely beautiful I really enjoy
being there so today I will talk about
some work but we are doing in our group
bottle and I will talk about the use of
artificially induced genetic variability
and show you some new work but we're
doing is not unfinished stories we are
still working on that but I wanted to
share you to share with you some result
the result result result battery God and
the strategy that we are currently using
to identify the genes and alleles that
are underlying phenotypic traits quality
traits in a tomato so as we said before
i'm from badal badal it's a beautiful
town well known for a seaside which is a
wide sea side and also of course for
wine and actually in our lab we are
working on tomato not only grape and
this is because as i will show you later
tomato is a wonderful model for fleshy
fruit so this is all up you are John
club between in hua and bottle
University and we will have pleasure to
welcome you at the end of this year to
resolve meeting in bottle Ian and of the
October so as I said before tomatoes and
modern food for many fleshy
including break which is also a berry
and what fantasy Dean is mostly early
foot development before ripening and
especially the cell expansion stage
where most of the fruit weight is gained
by the fruit the largest increase in the
fruit weight during this ages before
after a cell division and beef over
ripening and what happens is that during
the cell expansion th you have a huge
increase in South Side South Side can go
from 50 micron in some varieties to one
millimeter length so you can almost see
the the cell with a naked eyes and what
happens you have a large increase in a
cell backhaul increase in soluble
content struggles organic acid ions and
so on you have also and this is
something where to don't find any grape
but virtue adding that in a tomato you
have a shift from my duty cycle to on
the cycle which is amplified the essay
cycle and a large increase in nucleus
loyalty and of course your the storage
of the starch that disappears during
ripening and membrane cell wall and
catechol biosynthesis to to cope with
this drought increasing in woodside so
what fantasy dings and I will talk a
little bit about that and see the
mechanism but I involved in fruit
development at B cell expansion says
and the regulation coordination of these
processes so i will talk about two
strategies that you have been using in
the last year's the first one going from
candidate identifying candidate genes
and going to the findit ugh and this is
as I said before and publisher research
we are still working on that but i will
show you how we try to to tackle this
question so what you are doing this is
the fruit you have a couple world here
Perry cap and within the food we have
been into sending to expanding tissues
between after cell division working
okay after cell division said to be on
set of ripening so we have been looking
at these cells here in the mezzo gap and
you can see that you have a large
increase in cell size and the other
tissues we have been looking at is
tissues in the local at issue in virgil
where you have also large increase in
cell size but besides are clearly
different another a different fate so we
have been looking at that doing
metabolome analysis transavia analogies
besides in donor some time ago so it was
with a microwave and you can see that
the tissues local a tissue and missile
gap tissue of the cells are clearly
different are the same trajectory but
are clearly different and for example if
you look at the sucrose here it mostly
accumulates in the local ah tissues and
the same for garba and so on so clearly
we have two tissues but are evolving
during the cell expansion but butta
clearly also different and we did the
same for trans hips what we were mostly
interested in regulatory genes and what
we did is correlations between for
example one metabolite here in one
metabolite here glutamine trans hips and
so on and we had a server version above
pair wise wise correlation and we went
for looking at this correlation between
metabolite gene and then between genes
and other genes and metabolites and
looking for haps but ah in that case
jeans with high number of correlations
and what we wanted to know is whether
this
but show strong regulation will be to
tissues at the pre stage of development
could be involved in what you can
proceed in cell expansion our transition
to oversee ages so we draw a very basic
correlation and network and we had
several genes but we're identified does
helps among them what we had and I think
many people here know been quite well
much better when I do bourbon and we
know that this gene is very important
for in the triggering the onset of
ripening no this is the same this is a
mutant very important for reckoning ap2
we know that one homologue has been
recently been shown to be regulating
fruit ripening and these two genes with
no information and so we had were quite
continent that these genes could be
important for regulating fruit ripening
because the other candidate coming out
we're already identified those important
regulators so we have been looking into
that this is the two gene one is multi
expressive during sandy said expansion
and then decrease later there were one
mostly increasing after at the end of
each cell expansion but what is quite
interesting is vast be jeans because we
were working on sir expansion visions
have their expression modified before we
mature a green stage so during the
cellar expansion so we have been
using the tools available using what we
developed before a fruit specific
promoter that is strongly expressed
during the cell expansion sage and this
promoter drive expression specifically
in those cells that are undergoing
expansion verb hood this is in
comprising 35 as a promoter so what we
did is a very special Aaron I know
resort and then Kwazii technology which
basically allows us to other kind of the
dominant negative mutant for this basic
factor and what we have is these foods
are whiter accumulate much less starch
than the white add fruit which may
reserve resulting reduce a creation of a
glucose fructose later during ripening
marmalade increased firmness which can
be related to effect on fruit ripening
because what we saw is that this Toronto
ignites the different ultralink that we
are the strong effect on fruit ripening
so we have been looking at that in
detail you can see the differences
between busy family why type and you
can't cure see better a bragger onset of
ripening plus seven days it's almost
like already ripe in white up what it
you are right foot after 15 days after
break and stage so we are the strong
pointed we are working of that and
working on different
different strategy to try to understand
how vision can be controlling food
writing I won't go into the detail but
what I would like to insist on today in
my talk today is the second strategy but
we began to to use to develop few years
ago which is to go to identify mutants
and to go from phenotype to the function
of a genie so one of the reason as i
showed before reverse genetics approach
can be quite successful we have tools
now and it was very really basic at that
time but i think what is done now with
on a second ages large correlation
network began a very good inside upon
the putative function of genes but still
we need to do plant transformation we
don't know whether it can have a
phenotype or not because it can be
redundant and functions and so on and
what we wanted to develop what you did
is to go for forward genetic approaches
so far in tomato especially i think by
wonderful resources develop rita natural
viability but most cases what you need
is to have a large pizza
greenhouses human resource on and so on
and I like very much this picture from
dennys amia for example with collecting
fruit in echoing the north of Israel and
I think most of a lot at least all do
not have this facility what you have is
that growth chambers green now certain
Antoine so what we did and we began but
10 or 15 years ago it's to develop
artificially induced genetic diversity
in tomato and for that we choose the
miniature recursive a microtome and
because it can be a very nice additional
source of a genetic diversity for
functional studies of target gene when
you american idiot for gene discovery
and i will show you how how all sources
of a new elite for breathing and one
interesting thing is that generally
background is identical between all
mutants except for induce mutation so
what we chose choses this miniature
acute liver because it you can grow them
in windows your own identity short cycle
the carries these two recessive mutation
what one is Worf but but affects
brassinosteroid sentatives not in the
fruit but in the vegetative tissues
other plant and SP mutation which are
facts which control determinator growth
seconds has been genome has been second
recently and so it's quite well adapted
as a model
for functional genomics in tomato and
something that can be quite interesting
when you use microtome you cross it with
one of his old pound which is a
moneymaker this is f one that looks like
that is very similar to the moneymaker
parent so what we did and we did that
several years ago now we develop the
mutant connection we are currently using
8500 m two families fault inning for
identifying target genes mutations in
target genes and we did at the same time
finn'll typing at 3,500 families and
this has been store in a mutant database
that we are using what I have to say is
about ass about collection in my kodama
generated now one being in tsukuba
university and we have developed jointly
up for sharing these resources so how
can we use but as I said before you have
been throwing this phenotypic data in a
database you can search it for different
keywords and what we are currently doing
I won't talk about that today but it's
very very interesting screening for
vitamin C and mutants and it has been
done for sugar mutants and you can have
mutant with as much sugar van in grape
for example and something but we are
being soon is to screen for starch
mutant so this is just to show you give
you an idea of the diversity that you
have actually you've got more than three
thirty five thousand different
annotations and mutations but a
phenotypic adoration
we're a mutated so you can have a large
diversity but you find in natural
resources and pooch ate something that
is very strange-looking food color
aspect this one has been isolated which
is the critical mutant and I will talk
about that today is we're interested in
in fruit mythology foot size and fruit
motto mythology and this is the work
from Lucy thermal data and the other
work i'm going to talk about witches
work from you want booty with the
currently at the comment for two weeks
is food surface aspect and katakana so
what we are first trade i will focus on
is food sighs so fruit size depends on
both cell number kapil number so this is
determined mostly or in part before a
full set and then after fruit at UC lava
cell division that will determine the
number of cells and you have also sell
an almond but with Jetta mind the size
of a cell and depends in tightly Caray
created in tomato to auto replication
process nucleus quality and so what you
see here is from the auto pay cut to the
inside of fruit and you have a cross
section of the tomato / kao so what we
have been looking looking at is mutant
in with the variation in fruit size and
or variation in a perk up thickness so
this is how we do it we screen do such
database for example put large food
looking at what we have in a database
including pictures confirm but
phenotypes by growing the plants and
this is what we can get for example this
is why tag fruit you can see here from
Europa outer epidermis inner epidermis
mizuka yeah very large cells this mutant
which is a large fruit size mutant you
can see that you're more cells layer but
mostly larger cells and listening to an
increased this is say value here
increase on the way Reggie application
so you have large cells with larger new
clips in that case what you have is fin
para cup smaller cells but in that case
it see it is uncoupled from other
education because you see love large
nucleus but small cells so to understand
how rough a process proceeding tomato
these mutants can be quite
cursing so what we are doing is to work
on this different mutants car tires
lemons wrong this is a principal
component analysis and for example what
we can see here is what we cannot small
foods with small cells but we've both
high ployee and low Khloe low ploidy but
waiting for but in that case we can have
a smart fruit a small sad mutant with
the high blue again we are much
interested in understanding how Khloe is
controlling our sets eyes on fruit side
and these are very nice artwork so this
is water I said before it can be very
useful material so we wanted and we are
focusing on several of these mutant
libre will show you an example on this
one which is a thin very cap mutant with
low ploidy and you can see here but
we're very cap is very thinner than in a
white output and it has also that we
don't see it much here in different
shape and what you have done hand I will
go rapidly wait what you are doing is to
begin to do a rough characterization of
this mutant so if you look at fruit
weight in two different conditions one
with a controlled fruit number one with
the uncut work for the number in both
cases in blue fruit weight is lower it
has also an effect on fruit farmers here
you have a white hat here and you have
two different generation of this mutant
b c 1 f 21 f way i won't go into the
details these are the two colors but
anyway firmness is higher in that mutant
and this is not you because fruit size
is very often dependent on seed number
inaccurately base mutant as even more
seeds than white at so we have a small
fruit mutant with high seed number more
do i matter hi farmers and we have been
looking at tissue level details so what
we what we did is to look at cross
sections but you see here whiteout and
the mutant looking at her gap thickness
again we can't cure is he fat pack up
thickness is different using it tomato
analyzer developed by Esther evonik nap
we did the same port barre cap area
etiology but it's different and to be
did also a ploidy measurement and we see
here Cody index it's low ploidy mutant
but when we look there so it was quite
interesting trying to understand why
this pack up thicknesses
I smaller we have been looking at the
cell tissue structure different cells
and what we saw and this is quite
interesting is that we mean cell area is
much lower in the mutant what you have
is more or less you say molars because
it's very difficult to be sure about the
smallest person some knob of Sally areas
but what we saw and it's not clear from
here this is white hat you look in the
metal cup you have only large cells
except around the vessels but in the
mutant what we saw is about B cells
summer besides inside of the
differentiating expanding and so on are
still undergoing cell division so we
still of we believe my duty cycle and
this can last until ripening search so
we clear on how the different control
other probably the shift from my duty
cycle to be under cycle in that mutant
and we have also look at the different
different traits the timer to ripening
has more or less the same even shorter
in that mutant we have some defects
which are not from catechol defects with
brawn a spot but what we clearly see
also and we couldn't separate this trait
from this backup thickness suede is that
we are the differencing and ripening and
we are uneven ripening in the mutant
and looking more in detail about at
ripening what we could see is that
actually it takes much more time after
breaker set to reach right web our stage
in the mutant so what we believe is but
we are still working on that we have a
mutant where you effect early fruit
development and at the same time you
also affect ripening so later stages of
good development so of course this is
quite interesting trying to look these
both processes and we wanted to know
which in is underlying this weight of
this straight we have been looking
before that we have been looking a
little more bit more in detail tomato
fruit normally accumulates soluble
sugars this is why Todd recommends two
sugars these are mutant lines and
clearly put composition a different we
don't accumulate glucose or fructose and
we are we looking but these are very
preliminary work looking at the
expression of known ripening regulators
or ATM induced jeans and what you can
see is that all the expression of all
vision is strongly delayed compared to a
white up fruit so as I said before what
we wanted to do was to identify the
mutation so a strategy that you have
been using is matting by sequencing
taking advantage of the availability of
a tomato denim since two years now and
current development of the next
generation sequencing technology
so one classical way for that is to
across the mutant before for example
pampinea volume which is another close
but white tomato species problem that we
are viewing button working for example
on food sighs mitten is if you do but
crossing my cotton with something that
is quite different what you without in
after segregating population is
segregating for many many different
rates including take a precursor precise
on and so on so it can be very
problematic and this is the case for
that we saw that poor catechol when you
have a braced one mutation you can't
steal phenotype population one it's more
different less severe mutation is very
difficult so what we did is to go for
for angela's mapping on the x box a
going and analysis so the idea has to
cross the mutant the yellow mutant we
white out my cotton but doesn't carry a
mutation in case because this is a more
simple case monotonic recessive mutation
which was the case of a thin like a
pollutant you can go to be c 1 a 2 and
then you have a segregation between
plants showing the white up phenotype
and plan showing mutant phenotype you
can bulk them to balt white up like a
mutant like and then you can go for
would the normal second thing what
really using alumina comparison with a
reference genome nice
I think the rivet is that the only
source of genetic and phenotypic
variability are the EMS mutation this
mutation can be used as SNP markers
later and we'll show but this is very
useful so we did that what so what you
can wait for when you have a recessive
mutation caused an mutation or more
cycles here in yellow and this is
unlinked mutation in in green if you
look at unlinked mutation in motor
guttenberg of white add back the
frequency will be a point five when you
look at the mutation but you are
interested in with the causal mutation
what you are waiting for is a frequency
of one in the mitten bulk but you are
because you took out all the plants with
mutant phenotype frequency is reduced in
the wiretap back so we did that and this
is water I explained before for example
an leak mutation if you look at our
chromosome but doesn't carry a mutation
you have a mean frequency around point
five if you look at one region in a
chromosome that charisma mutation but
unlinked region the same frequency and
then when you go close very close will
cause a mutation frequency of the
mutated allele increases but that we
opposite in the mutant
dark and what you are waiting for here
is the causal mutation but other with a
frequency of one or you cannot relate a
linkedin mutation that have also high
frequency so we did that in that case
for example we didn't have so many seeds
so we have been working on very small
population we have been working on 170
two or three bc one actual individuals
we score the different phenotypes we are
be expected segregation by twenty-five
percent add the Phinn Pike after noted
that go segregated with ripening
phenotype and then we constitutive
different bugs for example analysis of
different rates principal component
analysis bulk only seconds and this is
what we get after second thing so we did
wooden am second seeing 30 to 40 X
coverage and this is the different
chromosomes why but do not carry the
mutation yeah you can't see this is the
this is a sliding windows for EMS
mutations you can see that the curves
are almost at the same level in the case
of mutant and white add bulk but info
chromosome the charisma mutation you
have a clear and huge difference in
these frequencies in some cases i will i
want to show you in different mutant we
working with larger population we ended
up with
we were cause a mutation in just 11
analysis in that case we had a smaller
population what we did is to use we
identify chromosome we are different
candidate Regent showing this Smith
frequency ratio but who were waiting for
for example this one we designed using
the different EMS mutation we designed
the markers which are Casper markers
quite easy to do and chip to do and use
again a simple relation to find map
mutation and what we found actually is
that this mutation was not close to some
trauma region but it was in a wreck
Amendment region which was nice but we
didn't identified and we did using
markers doing analysis of recombinant
Antoine we didn't identify any causal
mutation in this region so but we knew
that mutation was bad what we did in
that case is to go back to the data and
to look at all different mutation
because EMS actually is known to cause
base base transition but what we know
and some other groups did the same in
tomato we know but we have not only base
base transition we have also
translations and we have also in terms
and actually mutation was identified
again by looking at the mutations were
that were filtered filtered out in the
first step and we identify a 1t
direction
one Ginia and you clearly see here the
frequency in the mutant bulk and in the
white hat back but is very close to what
we are waiting for and what we did again
using different mutation certain maka we
could without any adopt assign the
mutation this mutant this is why tap and
you can clearly see that this mutation
is responsible for the mutant phenotype
so now I've got this point this is very
recent work actually we need the second
thing in august-september when we be
analysis and we came to butter a few
weeks ago and you had this point now and
actually the Canada gene that is
responsible for the phenotype but you
observe is a good bunny lat binding
protein we don't know much from all what
I've seen on that were role in plants
possibly involved in see cyclic GMP
signaling and base may interfere with
our almond signaling pathway cheaper in
oxon a chill on nitric oxide and this is
the question we are working on second
one is to be absolutely sure we know
that pimple cap is linked to this
problem of cell division using the
different markers larger population we
want to be absolutely sure but this
delayed ripening is you to the same
mutation as the one responsible for that
so this is one example of the strategy
that you are using I will just talk few
min
about another work that you have done on
foot category again same strategy going
through database identifying mutants
borrowed foot surface happened different
gross imminent you can see that they are
compared to white up garmo shiny and
dull mutants so what you have done and
this is the work of you one is to
identify series we are not working on
all one other glossy millions series of
dar mutants and analyzing these we could
add some ideas of the the processes but
control fruit or Chinese glossiness and
just to give you an example of how
interesting it can be formed by your
tech application later this is urine is
working by one but he may have some
forgot some tubes in the fridge what he
did and this is why tab mutant one year
after being in the fridge white a mutant
catechol affected mutant and another
critical affected mutant but in that
case but mutant sill after one year
showed very good appearance so this can
be quite interesting for looking at
critically affect on a shelf life on and
form but what I want to show you is how
we try to an onion identify the
underlying jeans so as I said before
this is an auto perk up your very
critical here and catechol is made of
polyester one is cutting the aloha boxes
with different components and this is
cutting total are cutting load on these
different mutants so you can see but in
big glossy mutant we have several
cutting deficient mutant we identified
the first one which actually is a coach
in sentence form a better cloning and
this one we wanted to go for this BSA
angels mapping strategy so we have done
that again a different boat in that case
we have been working with four hundred
or even 600 BC 1f to plant again you can
clearly see but the chromosome that
carries the mutation you have a clear
difference in the snip frequencies
narrowed down to different snips in one
region 10 to 15 snips and again we could
identify firstly but was presenting
homozygous mutant line and responsible
for mutation and actually what we saw is
that bad mutation was a glisten to
arginine mutation in batching which was
kept at a glycerol phosphate oscilla 28
and this mutation is very close to a
domain but is responsible for catalytic
activity of the enzyme and you introduce
a charged amino acid next to base
to base domain and we think this is
responsible and you are working on that
demonstrate that responsible for the
loss of activity of G pad and former
critical phenotype and G pad is
well-known anthem but is involved in the
synthesis of Eugene monomers so these
are just two snapshots of the current
work but we are doing on the biz mutants
something that is far from being
finished but i think a demonstrate how
we can identify genes we wouldn't think
of before or new elites for non genes
but might other some importance for
applied aspects in proper bringing
tomato for bring one main advantage of
these microtome mutants be strategy
which is one table you know RINO's and
you can have one wore a population
segregating population on four square
meters so that means that you can grow
them but your round in green us you can
have different population phenotype am
then go for four second singh and if you
are lucky if it's in recombinant region
and so on you can straight identify the
regime and you are currently and we
seconds different mutants with idle
mutants when Laura why year this double
abnormal microtome cracking aspects
vitamin c m and so on and just one of
the last night you can further go and
use this mutant collection for looking
for a latex service
regine that you identified before one
example of this gene which is involved
in carotenoid by the disease in the food
we have isolated several mutant missense
mutation but do not cause any effect on
the property function of a protein white
a phenotype and then miss intimidation
again listen to arginine mutation song
effect and you get the tangerine
phenotype the same Griffith cow mutant
and in that case you accommodate assist
like openness inside of a trance-like
open so I think now we begin with tomato
genome sequence but is available not
only for ions but also for different
cultivars with all the tools and the
other very nice to all busy this morning
the facilities here I think with a
genome sequencing bio informatics and so
on we have all the tools i think in
tomato to use these mutants but i think
it's the same for all plants crop
species in which we can have EMS
collection and next we can also use but
this has been known for a while Timmy
kidding to identify a leak service so i
would like to present you the people
named in my group will participate in
all that work lucy is carrying out all
the work on the food side mutant yawn
but is here on catechol and danielle is
somebody that is central to all mutant
collection greenhouse on and so on and
cecile GP and so on have been working on
all this Angela's mapping and did a very
good job on that with a virginie and
Martin was carrying out all the work on
the basic transient factor that I showed
you at the beginning and of course we
are not working alone and you have been
working with different books and I
forgot for example a leaf or metabolome
Advani from maximum is residing in gold
in Germany for metabolism and so on so I
wish to thank you for your attention
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu